[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat et de reportages sur
Public Sénat en étant ensemble tous les
jours à 18h pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et voici
le sommaire de ce 11 mai le maire de
Saint-Brévin annonce sa démission après
les agressions dont il a été victime le
22 mars dernier c'est voiture la façade
de sa maison incendie après une
polémique alimentée par l'extrême droite
sur le déplacement d'un centre d'accueil
des demandeurs d'asile près d'une école
quelle a été la réponse de l'État face
aux menace visant cette élu où on est la
répartition des demandeurs d'asile en
zone rurale voulu par Emmanuel Macron on
en débat dans une minute et puis c'est
l'une des priorités du ministre de
l'éducation nationale la lutte contre la
ségrégation sociale il n'y a pas
d'amélioration sur la question des
inégalités et ça vous avez raison c'est
extrêmement préoccupant parce que
forcément c'est la question de la
promesse républicaine presque de
méritocratie où on voit que que les
enfants
issus de de milieux sociaux économiques
modestes et bien ont vraiment beaucoup
moins de chances de réussir que les
autres enfin d'améliorer la mixité
scolaire pas Penga et réunissait
aujourd'hui les recteurs d'académie pour
leur donner une feuille de route mais
pas d'annonce officielle sa conférence
de presse a été annulée quelle
difficulté rencontrent le ministre
notamment avec les établissements privés
comment lutter contre les lycées ghetto
doit-on conditionner les subventions aux
écoles privées à les objectifs de mixité
réponse dans trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord un maire qui jette l'éponse face
à la violence yannique Mores quitte la
commune dans laquelle lui et sa famille
vivaient depuis 32 ans Nadia leur joue
après six ans à la tête de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins Yannick Morez
jette l'éponge les diles d'hiver droites
défend le transfert sur sa commune d'un
centre d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile
mais après de violentes intimidations et
plusieurs manifestations de l'extrême
droite il a présenté sa démission hier
soir au préfet de Loire-Atlantique j'ai
pris cette décision pour les raisons
personnelles notamment suite à
l'incendie criminel perpétré à mon
domicile et au manque de soutien de
l'État et après une longue réflexion
menée avec ma famille son renoncement a
fait réagir jusqu'au plus au sommet de
l'État évidemment ce qui s'est produit
est très choquant et je voudrais assurer
le maire de tout mon soutien la ministre
en charge des collectivités
territoriales de l'uniforme à contacter
ce maire et ça montre qu'il y a une
montée de l'extrémisme dans notre pays
et évidemment il faut qu'on soit très
très vigilant sur ce sujet
l'extrémisme il vaut des deux côtés et
je pense qu'en apportant des bonnes
réponses à nos concitoyens et à quoi je
veux m'employer ici la main dans la main
avec les aiguilles locaux c'est comme ça
qu'on évitera c'est monter de des
extrémismes avec des situations
inacceptables comme celle que vous avez
mentionné Elisabeth borne recevra
Yannick morrèze la semaine prochaine
mais la réaction est tardive l'élu de
Saint-Brévin dénonce depuis des semaines
le manque de soutien de l'État y compris
après l'incendie volontaire de son
domicile et de ses deux voitures le 22
mars dernier un acte violent en lien
avec le transfert du centre d'accueil
ouvert il y a 7 ans 400 demandeurs
d'asile ont été reçus sans incident une
tristesse forcément parce que pour avoir
été élu dans les collectivités dans une
mairie on sait tout l'engagement que ça
nécessite c'est de l'engagement en temps
c'est d'un engagement complet et lorsque
vous êtes menacé dans votre vie privée
lorsque vos enfants se sentent menacés
lorsque votre domicile est menacé pour
avoir vécu ce type de situation à la
fois dans mon domicile personnel et à ma
permanence à La Roche-sur-Yon et bien
évidemment que c'est une triste décision
nous nous devons de soutenir tous les
élus qui font un travail au quotidien
formidable c'est qu'il a partagé
également hier soir en partie par
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui c'est
le Parlement européen qui s'est levé
hier la haine a gagné en France et en
Europe
alors il est temps aujourd'hui de
rappeler que nous sommes attachés au
droit et aux principes humanistes qui
font de la construction européenne il
est temps de se lever de se lever en
l'honneur de Yannick borez de se lever
pour le droit et de me laisser le chemin
[Applaudissements]
l'année dernière en France les
agressions des Lions ont augmenté de 32
% des agressions directement liées à
l'exercice de leurs fonctions
j'accueille tout de suite mes invités
Françoise Gatel bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénatrice Union centriste de
l'Ille-et-Vilaine et présidente de la
délégation collectivités territoriale et
à la décentralisation Pascal Perino
bonsoir politologue professeur la
Science Po Paris Florent a dit au
bonsoir président du cercle de réflexion
l'été ri et Guillaume d'arrêt et
politique bonsoir Guillaume bienvenue à
tous encore une fois Françoise Gates je
commence avec vous c'est le constat
d'une impuissance étatique cette
histoire c'est d'abord très sincèrement
un funeste jour parce que quand ta mère
j'ai de l'éponge ça veut dire que c'est
une blessure qui est faite à la
République et ça doit nous interroger et
cette démission elle associe de
particulier qu'elle s'ajoutent à de
nombreuses d'émissions et qu'elle
soulève plusieurs problèmes d'abord le
fait que amer il est vraiment au
corps-à-corps avec l'action publique
avec ses habitants ses concitoyens ou
apparemment ça se passait bien et puis
aujourd'hui ce que j'appellerai des gens
qui veulent semer la tempête et qui un
jour feront nous la récol et qui
viennent semer le trouble et que ce
maire a été victime d'incendie dans sa
maison d'agression ski juste
inimaginable mais que la question que
moi je voudrais que l'on pose au-delà de
l'émotion que nous ressentons c'est
comment se mère a-t-il eu l'impression
de se sentir tout seul c'est pour ça
dans la gestion de ce sujet voilà alors
il existe dans notre Constitution un
principe de précaution qui trop souvent
paralyse notre action publique et là
aujourd'hui moi je dis avec beaucoup de
gravité il s'agit de prendre soin et
d'avoir un principe de précaution à
l'égard de la République et de ceux qui
la font parce que ce maire il portait la
décision de l'État pour installer enfin
c'est juste déplacé il était ce centre
il était là dans la dans la ville depuis
7 ans depuis 2016 voilà et un cadavre
qui apparemment ne posait pas de
problème mais cela
et cela faisait suite à ce qui s'est
passé en Bretagne à Callac sur un sujet
un peu identique et je pense que cela
veut dire que si on a un vrai principe
de précaution et un vrai principe
républicain on doit être collectivement
et l'État et les élus locaux mais lui il
a été attentif à la manière de procéder
pour tenter d'éviter le maximum de
dégâts sans parler des manifestations
très malsaines après il y a aussi
l'instrumentalisation d'un thème on y
reviendra évidemment dans dans ce débat
Pascal Perrineau on parle souvent dans
sauvagement de la société française
est-ce que vous y voyez un signe
supplémentaire de l'ensemble de manière
résidente
c'est vraiment je reprends l'adjectif ce
funeste événement
est lié à un double mouvement il y a oui
une violence qui ne cesse de monter dans
la société française ce que Jean-Pierre
Chevènement appelait jadis lance
sauvagement ce que notre appel la
brutalisation de la société française il
y a des indicateurs très objectifs de
cela c'est par exemple la hausse de la
petite et de la moyenne délinquance avec
recours à la violence physique ça ce
sont des indicateurs pas qui sont là et
qui montre bien qu'il y a un mouvement
d'emba et puis ce mouvement d'en bas
rencontre le mouvement d'en haut c'est à
dire sur la scène politique
une extrémisation de la vie politique
une polarisation du débat par les
extrêmes que ce soit l'extrême gauche
pensons à la violence depuis des
semaines et des semaines dans les
grandes manifestations de protestations
contre la réforme des retraites des
Black Blocs et pensons ce qui a fait
l'événement depuis quelques jours ou
défilé du guide dans les rues de Paris
il y a là en effet deux forces qui au
plan politique j'allais dire ne cesse de
jeter de l'huile sur le feu et légitime
quelque part le retour à la violence et
le recours à la violence ce qui fait que
individu et bien voilà maintenant sur le
terrain local face à des mers face à
l'acte et face à l'acte en effet de
mettre l'incendie dans une maison ou
d'ailleurs ils auraient pu emporter et
brûler une famille c'est pas ça qui les
arrête et ça c'est extrêmement
inquiétant parce que je terminerai par
là les maires c'est le dernier rempart
de la République et de la démocratie sur
le terrain alors où la démocratie fait
l'objet de multiples contestations et
donc ça ça pose aussi la question de la
responsabilité de la parole politique
donc là on a déjà deux thèmes qu'on va
évidemment creuser ensemble
l'impuissance de l'État la
responsabilité des politiques quand ils
prennent la parole Florent Vaillot on
peut dire malheureusement que la
stratégie d'intimidation elle a
fonctionné
à Saint-Brevin avec voilà le risque d'un
précédent c'est-à-dire que est-ce à quel
point ça peut libérer la tentation pour
d'autres de voilà de d'agir de la même
façon puisque un maire a cédé vous avez
raison effectivement c'est une stratégie
d'intimidation en tout cas son résultat
est l'intimidation il faudra voir si
dans l'enquête il y avait pas une
volonté de ne pas aller jusque à
l'incendie et criminel parce que ils
font qu'on n'a pas appréhendé les
responsables on ne saura pas qu'elle
était leurs intentions réelles souvent
on a vu des des simulacres qui
dégénéré en quelque sorte mais dans tous
les cas c'est cela ce qui est certain
c'est que aujourd'hui sur la prise de
décision politique à quelques soient les
niveaux il y a aujourd'hui une frilosité
beaucoup plus importante qu'auparavant
avec la question de la violence qui
s'immis avec la question des
mobilisations et de fait ça ça effrite
la capacité de prise de décision de
tenue des arbitrages de réalisation de
de ces chantiers là mais n'allons pas
voir non plus je pense une espèce de
robinet d'eau tiède qui risque de de
devenir le courant de l'action politique
c'est ce que vous nous dites nos menaces
face aux intimidations bien sûr mais on
le voit à divers degrés par exemple les
recours systématiques les recours
juridiques systématique contre tout
projet public d'aménagement c'est une un
degré zéro en quelque sorte de
l'intimidation politique on a
aujourd'hui une gamme d'action qui s'est
divertissait
diversifiée pardon un répertoire
d'action qui va de la juridicisation en
passant par la médiatisation jusqu'à la
violence parce qu'effectivement il y a
des mouvements politiques qui sont aux
franges pour le rappeler qui font de la
violence un mode d'action politique et
c'est ce qui s'est aujourd'hui exprimer
alors il y a évidemment eu beaucoup de
réactions politiques de messages de
soutien au maire de Saint-Brevin mais
malheureusement j'ai envie de dire comme
à chaque fois à chaque fois qu'un élu
est confronté à la violence à chaque
fois qu'un maire démissionne il y en a
eu beaucoup d'autres bah il y a toujours
plein de messages de de soutien on
pourrait revenir mais on en a choisi
parce que c'est vous en avez vu un
extrait dans le reportage d'ouverture
c'est la colère exprimée par le l'euro
député Raphaël luxmann qui aura fait se
lever une partie du Parlement européen
aurait écoute une partie de cet extrait
hier le maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
Yannick Morez a été acculé à la
démission après des mois de menaces de
mort contre lui et sa famille des mois
de harcèlement par l'extrême droite
après avoir vu sa voiture et sa maison
brûlée en pleine nuit alors qu'il
dormait avec sa femme quel est le crime
commis par Yannick Morez aux yeux des
agents de la haine et du chaos sont seul
crime et d'avoir accepté l'établissement
d'un centre d'accueil dans sa commune
pour demandeurs d'asile d'avoir respecté
notre droit et nos principes hier
la haine a gagné en France et en Europe
alors on a choisi cet extrait parce que
Rafael Luxman cible nommément l'extrême
droite des mois de harcèlement par
l'extrême droite Françoise Gatel quel
est pour vous la part de responsabilité
de l'extrême droite et nos mollets de
d'Éric Zemmour et de son mouvement
reconquête puisqu'ils étaient en
première ligne contre le déménagement de
ce centre d'accueil oui moi j'aime
beaucoup le propos de Glucksman parce
que il est clair sur la gravité de la
situation il va au-delà de l'émotion et
que je pense enfin moi ce que j'ai lu de
la faire c'est que on a identifié des
personnes qui étaient déjà présents dans
un autre
centre enfin dans une autre commune et
c'était en Bretagne à Calac où il y
avait une association qui voulait
installer un centre d'hébergement et que
cet homme est connu c'est présenté à des
élections sous l'étiquette politique que
vous évoquez et donc cet homme il est
venu répondre enfin moi je le dis très
calmement il est venu répondre la haine
et la subversion dans dans une commune
donc on voit bien aujourd'hui la
première ministre l'a dit je pense que
la République
elle est prise en étau entre les
extrêmes les Black Blocs que l'on voit
dans les manifestations si tout aussi
dangereux et risqués que c'est
extrêmement hâte qui aujourd'hui
rejaillit comme dans les périodes
troublées parce qu'à un moment je pense
que l'efficacité de l'action publique
n'est pas au rendez-vous et que nous
avons des concitoyens qui ont
l'impression d'être dépassés débordés
certains disent c'est terrible de ne
plus habiter chez eux ils ont plus
d'espoir donc on a une
je pense moi je dis pas qu'on a failli
mais en tout cas globalement c'est pas
très réussi tout ça et que au-delà de la
recherche de culpabilité d'émotion et
d'un atome qu'on se lance je pense que
reconnaître l'engagement de cet homme et
rendre hommage à la démission du maire
c'est en quelque sorte se dire bon on a
compris donc maintenant comment on fait
comment on travaille ensemble pour
exercer cette surveillance bienveillante
sur notre République
je reste sur la thématique de l'extrême
droite alors là aussi on va pouvoir
essayer d'être
précis et peut-être pas trop simpliste
et binaire parce qu'elle Perrine d'abord
un fait à l'Assemblée nationale seuls
les députés du rassemblement national
ont refusé de se lever pour pour
soutenir et rendre hommage au maire de
Saint-Brévin pourquoi ils envoient un
message alors base électoral historique
comment vous l'analysez je crois que
c'est un comportement extrêmement
condamnable le RN depuis son élection
sous forme de groupe nous avait habitué
j'allais dire à des initiatives un peu
plus heureuses depuis juin dernier dans
le cadre de sa volonté de montrer que
c'était une force démocratique attachée
à la défense de la culture républicaine
qui est un patrimoine commun là j'avoue
que ce type d'attitude est assez
surprenant c'est une erreur politique je
crois que si on est un peu cynique dans
l'analyse
de volonté de respectabilité
surtout ou alors il se sentent visés
mais pour l'instant d'ailleurs attendons
la fin de l'enquête on verra si oui ou
non les ou l'individu qui a mis le feu
fin mars à la voiture et aux voitures et
au domicile de sommaire vient des
milieux de l'extrême droite ou non donc
quelque part l'attitude est un peu
troublante et étrange et je crois que
c'est une faute de car après ce qui est
noté Thomas aussi on le voit aujourd'hui
c'est des critiques y compris à l'égard
de la majorité du gouvernement avec le
sentiment d'une partie de la gauche en
particulier qui est un peu de poids de
mesure entre une dénonciation
extrêmement forte de l'extrême gauche et
en particulier de la France insoumise de
ces violences des dernières semaines et
de ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui même
si effectivement enfin ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers jours même s'il faut
attendre la fin de l'enquête
ou effectivement on entend la première
ministre condamner les faits sans
rentrer effectivement dans le combat
politique c'est quelque chose
suffisamment de réaction enfin en tout
cas sont les critiques après le 22 mars
le moment où il y a eu ces incendie
flore a dit on l'a aussi on peut faire
extrême droite ultra droite de quoi on
parle d'après vous pour les services de
sécurité les services de renseignement
est ultra droite un groupe uscule qui
considère que le prolongement de
l'action politique passe par la violence
et donc il y a des rassemblements en vue
pas uniquement mais de perpéter
perpétrer des actes violents donc si le
l'auteur des faits appartient à cette
mouvance là il sera très clairement
appartenant à l'ultra droite l'extrême
droite normalement reste dans le champ
d'exercice politique démocratique il
peut en contester les fondements ça a
été le cas du Front national pendant
très longtemps ça n'est plus le cas du
rassemblement national et peut surtout
entretenir une porosité avec un discours
violent et dans la dernière élection
présidentielle
celui qui clairement à jouer sur ce
tableau là c'est Eric Zemmour on se
souvient de son discours lors du devant
la Tour Eiffel lorsque il y avait eu ces
militants qui avaient scandés des propos
d'une rare violence à l'égard des
membres du gouvernement il avait eu un
problème d'audition un moment donné
cette entretien justement de la porosité
entre on valide le recours par certains
la violence au moins la violence
fantasmée et certains de ses membres qui
peuvent passer à la violence ça permet
de faire glisser certaines mouvements
politiques du champ républicain à
l'ultra droites ou l'ultra gauche
lorsque c'est le cas Pascal permet
peut-être un mot sur cette porosité
extrême droite ultra droite oui on vient
une porosité en termes de mode d'action
de manière évidente mais ça ça n'est pas
en effet nouveau souvenons-nous en
prenant de la distance les années 30 la
manière dont une violence d'extrême
gauche pouvait nourrir une violence
d'extrême droite et vice-versa il y
avait ce fameux effet des rois entre ces
violences et j'ai l'impression que
comparaison n'est pas raison mais que
dans la situation de crise économique
sociale culturelle
que l'on traverse il y a à nouveau cet
effet de miroir et un espace dans sur la
scène publique pour ses forces radicales
qui étaient totalement marginalisées et
qui maintenant peuvent séduire telle ou
telle partie de la jeunesse telle ou
telle partie du du corps électoral sur
le thème vous voyez la démocratie c'est
pas la peine de compter sur elle si on
veut que les jauges les choses changent
passons à l'acte de la violence alors
là-dessus je crois que à la fois bien
sûr la réponse de l'institution
judiciaire de l'institution policière
doit être d'une fermeté extrême sans
aucune concession mais que les forces
démocratiques ont une part de
responsabilité je veux dire là-dessus il
ne faut pas d'ambiguïté il ne faut pas
que des grandes forces de gouvernement
qui voilà un jour on pourrait devenir
force de gouvernement alternative
pratique l'ambiguïté sur la condamnation
de la violence la violence elle doit se
condamner ici et maintenant quel que
soit son origine et même quand c'est la
violence j'allais dire de son camp au
sens large que ce soit les gauches ou
les droites Thomas j'ai une information
à vous donner en premier lieu le Sénat
puisque je peux vous dire ça sera
officiel dans quelques minutes que la
commission des Lois du Sénat
auditionnera justement le maire de
Saint-Brévin Yannick morhez le mercredi
17 mai mercredi 17 mai à 11h on a eu
l'information exactement au même moment
mais merci beaucoup de nous la donner
alors ce débat on l'a après l'annonce de
démission mais malheureusement on aurait
pu la voir et d'ailleurs ce sont des
thèmes qui ont été abordés au Sénat
plusieurs fois et on aurait pu avoir ce
débat à de nombreuses reprises sur ce
plateau pourquoi parce que des
démissions d'élus il y en a eu beaucoup
près de 4000 depuis 2020 pour et je
propose atteindre la nuit de nous
rejoindre pour évaluer l'ampleur des
violences suivies bonsoir Tam on peut
s'appuyer sur les travaux les textes qui
ont été évoqués ici au Sénat et
notamment après la mort du maire de
cygne Jean Matthieu Michel en août 2019
ce maire dont on se rappelle il est été
renversé par une camionnette après être
intervenu pour mettre fin à des dépôts
de gravats sauvages bien le Sénat lance
une grande consultation à l'époque plus
de 10% des mers répondent et 92% d'entre
eux ont fait l'objet de violence
verbales ou de violence physique alors
dans le rapport d'information il y a de
très nombreux témoignages mais vous en
donner quelques uns déjà parmi les plus
graves il y a cette tentative de meurtre
en 2004 avec une voiture comme arme pour
me tuer deux interventions chirurgicales
plus de 6 mois d'arrêt ou encore j'ai
reçu 9 coups de couteau et j'ai été
annoncé mort au journal de 20h il y a
aussi de nombreuses violences verbales
qui sont racontées on parle de menaces
de mort de diffamation ou encore de
situation de harcèlement ou
d'intimidation et là il y a alors
plusieurs témoignages qui résonnent
particulièrement avec ce qui s'est passé
à Saint-Brevin-les-Pins par exemple
alors que j'ai accueilli des familles
soudanaises réfugiées j'ai reçu un
courrier anonyme de menaces et j'ai
trouvé un couteau planté dans une
jardinière devant la mairie ou encore
incendie de ma maison la nuit du 1er
janvier 2013 alors que je me trouvais en
Pologne dans la cadre d'un jumelage ma
maison a été entièrement détruite par un
incendie le constat fait aussi état de
suite judiciaire trop peu fréquente peu
de plaintes encore moins de
condamnations il y a un manque de moyens
qui sont donnés aux maires un manque
d'accompagnement de l'État pour faire
face à ces violences que préconise le
Sénat à l'époque 12 propositions avec en
gros deux volets l'un pour renforcer
l'autorité des mères l'effectivité de
leur pouvoir de police et un second
volet pour mieux accompagner protéger le
maire dans l'exercice de son mandat ça
se concrétise dans une loi fin 2019 à la
loi engagement et proximité avec le
renforcement du pouvoir de police des
mères par exemple ou encore
l'élargissement de la protection
fonctionnelle des mers un système
d'assurance spécifique financé par la
collectivité puis la dernière avancée
législative en date c'est la loi de
Lattre qui permet aux associations
d'élus de se porter civile en cas
d'agression d'un élu dans le cadre de
ses fonctions et malgré cela le tableau
des violences contre les élus il est de
plus en plus sombre oui quasiment chaque
semaine on l'entend en question
d'actualité au Gouvernement les
sénateurs se font les cours des
violences faites aux élus et aussi du
problème des démissions d'élus qui
découlent de tout cela et dernièrement
et bien le 30 mars une sénatrice avait
déjà interpellé le gouvernement sur
l'événement dont on parle aujourd'hui
écouter cet échange la semaine dernière
la voiture et la maison du maire de
Saint-Brevin en Loire-Atlantique ont été
touchés par un incendie volontaire
comment allez-vous protéger ceux qui
font vivre notre République au quotidien
dans les 35 000 communes de France il y
aura une enquête pour pouvoir le
démontrer mais que du simple fait qu'il
est accepté la mise en place d'un centre
d'accueil pour réfugiés à la demande
d'ailleurs de l'État et c'est son rôle
de la suscepté il a été d'abord victime
de menaces de mort d'un jour puis
finalement à vue son domicile dégradé
avec l'incendie de ces deux voitures et
dégradations d'une partie de sa maison
par vous dites par qui madame la
sénatrice cette fois-ci c'est
probablement par l'extrême droite madame
les sadris nous devons faire ce travail
pédagogique pour aller expliquer aux
populations pour protéger les il font
partie de la Villa nation et s'attaquer
à ma mère c'est s'attaquer s'il vous
plaîtvin a démissionné il a dénoncé le
manque de soutien de l'État les
violences contre les mères et les élus
elles ont augmenté de 47 % en 2021 de
nouveau de 32 % en 2022 elles ont donc
presque doublé en deux ans merci Tam
Françoise gatelon je parlais du manque
de soutien de l'État enfin quand je
revois cette liste il y a des faits qui
datent de 2004 de de 2013 qui sont aussi
graves que que ce dont on parle ce soir
même s'il y a une loi même s'il y a eu
je le comprends bien une volonté voilà
c'est quoi c'est c'est impossible de
protéger tous les élus qui sont menacés
comment vous l'expliquez chose que c'est
sans doute impossible d'empêcher tout
accident
provoqué par des gens dont on ne sait
pas si son extrême droite extrême gauche
et des gens qui sont sensibles à des
discours un peu étranges mais cela était
dit je pense que le il incarne d'une
part une autorité
et puis il est celui que l'on voit celui
contre quel on
exprime en quelque sorte le désaccord la
désillusion et le maire il est tout seul
c'est-à-dire le maire les communes 35000
vous en avez 15 habitants vous avez des
grandes communes ou le main il en peut
plus de distance il est au coeur le
symbole de toutes les paroles publiques
quoi en quelque sorte
un punching ball mais à un moment le la
chose devient grave et que je pense
qu'il y a deux choses dans tout ça il
faut effectivement protéger les mains et
faire qui ne soient pas en danger de
mort il faut le dire et en plus il y a
la famille vous voyez ce qui pèse sur la
famille et ce qui fait quand même il
s'engage pour servir il s'engage pas
pour que sa famille soit victime de peur
risque être brûlé vous vous l'avez
rappelé donc
nous interrompre il est allé à la
gendarmerie grosso modo il a pas eu de
réponse moi je sais pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut dire que il y a
eu quelques programmes de la barre du
ministère de la Justice sur les côtes et
l'attention prêtée aux agressions d'élus
depuis la loi mais ça ne suffit pas et
qu'ensuite la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que ce maire comment le maire a
été accompagné par l'État c'est à dire
le préfet que je n'accable pas mais
c'est quand même le sujet pour installer
ou déplacer chez lui un cada qui lui a
été demandé par l'État est-ce qu'on
laisse le maire alors Monsieur le Maire
vous devez faire ça alors vous y allez
et on va voir et franchement mais tout
des thématiques
inflammables ou en tout cas utiliser
comme tel quoi aujourd'hui cela a été
dit dans une société qui est électrique
qui a peur de tout qui veut pas voir
l'étranger qui craint que même si rien
n'arrive on ne laisse pas amer tout seul
mener un projet de sa nature donc c'est
aussi la manière dont l'état est au
Sénat on a beaucoup travaillé sur la
manière dont dans les territoires les
préfets de départements ils ont des
services pour accompagner vous l'aviez
dit tout à l'heure on a vu quand il y a
eu le démantèlement à Calais comment
quand il y a eu des déménagements on va
dire de personnes en situation parfois
irrégulière dans des communes un peu
isolées comment l'État il a pris soin
d'accompagner socialement juridiquement
c'est possible et bah oui en tout cas
c'est possible et ça doit être fait ça
doit être fait et donc moi je pense que
vous l'avez dit on se désole on
compatisse exactement ce qui nous arrive
après des attentats alors on sort les
bougies on sort les roses on regrette
voilà sauf qu'à un moment nos
condoléances on va les offrir à la
République parce que le problème c'est
que demain matin qui va vouloir
s'engager comme mère
vous vous avez c'est pas de la désertion
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous demandez
l'Association des maires de France que
vous y êtes aussi elle fait quoi elle
aide elle a mis des moyens les
associations départementales
accompagnent aide porte plainte font des
actions de formation auprès des élus
avec la gendarmerie il y a des tas de
choses mais qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui
c'est est-ce qu'on peut aller au racine
du mal d'abord il y a ces mouvements on
l'a dit extrémistes qui vous surveiller
et puis je pense que c'est comment amer
il n'est pas que l'exécuteur est comme
orphelin de l'État parce qu'on
l'accompagne pas dans un exercice
difficile mais comment on exerce un
principe de précaution disant on doit
déplacer ce cada c'est très important
c'est notre mission de solidarité
Glucksman a appelé mais comment on va
réussir est-ce qu'on peut identifier les
risques et comment on conduit ce projet
il y a un peu de lait
je pense de manque d'attention pour être
aimable sur le sujet
la thématique immigration va on va y
revenir dans le dernier chapitre de ce
débat mais je voudrais conclure là sur
sur cette question de la de la parole
publique de l'Incarnation finalement de
l'autorité publique par le maire
Florent est-ce que est-ce que c'est la
est-ce que une sanction juridique
juridique pardon plus lourde peut
suffire c'est vrai que ça avait été il y
avait une proposition de loi au Sénat
pour que la sanction
d'une agression contre amer sur la même
que contre un policier ou un pompier par
exemple est-ce que ça ça suffit pour
vous il faut savoir qu'en droit pénal
plus vous accroissez les cantades de
peine et moins vous avez des faits en
réalité médiatique parce que les
condamnations sont toujours les unes
après les autres donc
l'aspect dissuasif de l'accroissement
des cantats de peine en matière ça ne
marche pas de la peine qui va changer
dans un acte de violence sauf lorsqu'il
est prémédité vous ne pensez pas
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va jusque là vous voyez la
réflexion mieux associée les citoyens
pour pour qu'on ait plus voilà ce
décalage et ce ressentiment là qui
s'exprime parfois dans la vie
certainement parce que ces individus
extrémistes qui passent à l'acte parfois
il se prévalent d'un soutien tacite dans
l'opinion ils sont de quelle mauvaise
humeur et cette mauvaise humeur elle
s'est installée pourquoi c'est parce que
il y a pas eu suffisamment de débat oui
par exemple dans cette commune c'est
l'histoire non pas de l'arrivée d'un
centre d'accueil mais du déplacement
dans l'espace communal à côté d'une
école très bien à partir du moment où
l'on a conscience qu'il y a par exemple
certains parents d'élèves qui disent
leur préoccupations etc d'un tel
déplacement il faut aussi que les
administrations d'État en liaison avec
les pouvoirs locaux entame un vrai
travail d'explication que par exemple le
rectorat Vienne au contact de ses
parents d'élèves que
l'administration de l'intérieur le
commissaire de police leur représentant
de la gendarmerie viennent au contact de
la pédagogie on entendait Olivier Véran
par les pédagogie tout à l'heure c'est
sûr c'est un travail d'explication est
très souvent ce travail d'explication
qui demande tout simplement du temps
mais j'allais dire la démocratie la
vraie sa demande du temps si on est un
homme une femme pressé faisons autre
chose ou allons dans les régimes
autoritaires là ça demande du temps si
ce travail était fait je crois qu'on
arriverait pas à éliminer bien sûr
totalement le comportement de quelques
malades ou de quelques toqués mais que
l'on ferait diminuer cette violence
politique tout à fait préoccupante qui
maintenant se retourne contre ceux qui
jusque dans les dernières enquêtes reste
tout de même pour une immense majorité
des Français les seuls hommes politiques
qui font l'objet d'une confiance
majoritaire à savoir les maires et à qui
on demande désormais de plus en plus y
compris entre le Président de la
République ou d'autres veut se réappuyer
sur eux pour renouer une confiance avec
les français Florent va dire ce que dit
Pascal Perrineau est très vrai parce que
l'administration d'État en région
n'explique jamais les décisions qu'elle
prend elle demande aux élus de se faire
le porte-parole et donc vous avez des
gens qui deviennent finalement le
symbole de la France vous l'avez sur le
samedi migration vous l'avez sur la
gestion de l'eau aujourd'hui vous avez
des problèmes majeurs sur la gestion de
l'eau et le maire va expliquer aux
agriculteurs à la population les
restrictions qui ont été prises il y a
une culture de l'administration des
concentré qui doit être aussi une
culture de l'imputabilité il faut savoir
rendre des comptes que l'on soit en
région ou à Paris il y a pas de
différence pour l'administration des
temps et alors c'est un cas d'école
évidemment passionnant c'est c'est
centre d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
avec cette volonté du Président de la
République donc de les éparpiller un peu
mieux sur le territoire projet
d'Emmanuel Macron annoncé au préfet
c'était en septembre dernier on écoute
un extrait du discours présidentiel
plusieurs d'entre vous sont des
territoires ruraux
quel que soit les engagements pris nous
devons fermer des classes
vraisemblablement des écoles et des
collèges
si nous savons
offrir de l'hébergement de l'urgence et
de l'intégration dans ces régions à des
femmes et des hommes qui arrivent sur
notre sol les conditions de leur accueil
seront bien meilleures que si nous les
mettons dans des zones qui sont déjà
dansément peuplées avec une
concentration de problèmes économique et
sociaux massif
ce projet moi je j'entends Emmanuel
Macron et puis bon on peut se dire c'est
frapper au coin du bon sens c'est aussi
un peut-être un chiffon rouge
agité pour une partie de la classe
politique à l'extrême droite comment
vous l'analysez ça non je trouve que
voilà bon pourquoi pas croyons chez moi
un peu idyllique que le Président de la
République présente mais ensuite faut
que ça suive parce que si on dit voilà
dans ces territoires il y a
potentiellement
un meilleur accueil potentiel qui peut
être fait que dans un milieu urbain dans
lequel il y aurait de multiples tensions
etc tout ça reste à prouvé d'ailleurs il
y a plusieurs villages où c'est déjà
arrivé où ça se passe bien donc faut pas
retirer
inutilement le tableau le service public
qui accompagne cet accueil qu'en terme
de
efficacité des administrations d'État au
plus près de l'action publique
c'est-à-dire dans les communes il faut
que ça suive si ça ne suit pas et bien
on arrive à la situation de ça voilà qui
tourne au drame heureusement ça ne
tourne pas toujours au drame mais qui
peut tourner au drame et qui tourne au
drame de plus en plus ce qui est
préoccupant donc méfions-nous des effets
d'annonces
oui moi je alors j'entends ce que dit le
président de la République sur le
principe ça peut être vrai seulement
faut pas oublier quelque chose dont nous
n'avons pas parlé que derrière tout ça
le sentiment de déclassement des
territoires qui sont éloignés qui
souffrent socialement qui ont pas de
mobilité et qui à un moment il faut le
dire ne se reconnaissent plus dans leur
environnement si vous dit voilà dans ces
territoires qui sont capables d'être
très accueillants vous l'avez dit et qui
peuvent et bien écouter on va nous nous
avons décidé de pouvoir permettre à des
personnes que le pays va accueillir de
s'installer non mais vous pouvez pas
imposer ça à des gens sans qui
comprennent parce que vous ça peut pas
être pyramidale c'est comme une greffe
quand vous faites une grève quand vous
êtes chirurgien que vous faites une
grève vous vous assurez que la grève va
prendre et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
parler il faut accompagner les gens il
faut que ce soit accepté et donc c'est
vous voyez c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'affection société
si les gens ils ont l'impression d'être
au bout du bout du couloir et que c'est
le tunnel qui n'ont pas de futur
écologique ou alors vous pouvez
accueillir des gens vous comprenez parce
que comme ça on ferme pas vos écoles les
gens ça leur tombe dessus comme quelque
chose qui l'aurait imposé parce que il
pourrait que la ville ne pourrait pas il
se sentent un peu accablés donc il faut
qu'on ait un travail différent qui soit
un travail collectif et positif ce qu'on
a vu des communes accueillir des
personnes qui venaient et c'est une
chance pour ces territoires et ça c'est
bien fait mais pourquoi on va vous
imposer à vous telle chose ce qu'on a
construit avec vous vous pouviez vous
avez de la place si ça allait vous
rendre service
si je dis pas de bêtises et je crois
qu'au moment il y a quelques années des
grandes des fortes vagues migratoires
notamment au début de la guerre en Syrie
cette idée avait déjà été émise et en
réalité on n'a jamais trouvé le nombre
de familles nécessaires pour aller
s'implanter dans ces territoires là le
problème n'était pas tant l'accueil que
quand on y avait une répartition qui
s'était faite au niveau européen la
France n'a jamais atteint en réalité le
nombre de personnes qu'on aurait pu
accueillir Florent va dire vous signez
dans l'humanité une tribune sur une
politique d'immigration de gauche
est-ce que c'est une mesure comme
celle-là pourrait y trouver sa place ou
pas alors d'abord il y a un précédent
quand j'étais au cabinet du garde des
sceaux en 2016 nous avons mis en place
une clé de péréquation pour que les
mineurs étrangers isolés les mineurs non
accompagnés désormais soient répartis
dans les départements de manière à ce
que il la charge ne repose pas sur
uniquement les départements d'entrée et
de de stationnement mais c'est ce
précédent là donc il existe et je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron c'est inspiré de cela
mais il existe pour une la raison très
simple c'est que la compétence du
Département c'est l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et que c'est mineur non
accompagné il ressortent de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance donc on part d'un
truc pour ensuite en faire une
généralisation c'est une folie parce que
à l'époque nous avons mis deux ans à
négocier avec la session des
départements de France il y a une
compensation financière de l'État et je
peux vous assurer que derrière
normalement un mineur non accompagné il
fait l'objet d'une prise en charge
financière extrêmement forte de la part
de l'État donc ce que annonce le
président de la République c'est qu'en
réalité si je fais un raccourci mais son
discours n'était guère plus éloquant que
cela vous fermez une école on fait un
cra à la place un centre de rétention
administrative ou un Caden centre
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile mais ça
ne marche pas comme ça parce qu'en
réalité ça voudrait dire que l'ensemble
de notre politique migratoire elle est
calculée précisément pour répartir la
charge mais que donc elle a les moyens
financiers de faire de l'accompagnement
de l'insertion et de la reconduite à la
frontière parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'ensemble du dispositif est défaillant
on ne sait pas intégrer mais on ne sait
pas reconduire non plus la frontière et
pourtant les budgets sont colossaux donc
une politique migrat cohérente elle
travaille à la fois sur l'insertion avec
y compris des accords proviseurs de
travail comme c'est le cas en Allemagne
ce qui permet au demeurant de créer des
capacités d'insertion mais aussi de
suivre les personnes en situation qui
n'ont pas de titre de séjour définitif
et on reconduit à la frontière et pour
reconduire à la frontière je peux vous
assurer qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
travail pour mettre en sur une même
ligne les services préfectoraux les
services de la Police aux Frontières
notamment donc je crois qu'il faut
sortir de la politique des trucs pour
arriver à penser de manière un peu plus
systémique le dispositif alors on va
terminer là-dessus il y a évidemment ce
projet de loi immigration dans les
tiroirs du gouvernement hier on vous
parlait de la valse hésitation entre
Emmanuel Macron dans les 100 jours puis
Elisabeth borne bah non c'est reporté on
n'a pas la majorité politique et puis
finalement ça va être présenté en
conseil de missrant en juillet Guillaume
DARES qui est sûr c'est que il y a un
point qui qui a un point d'achoppement
c'est la question de ce titre de séjour
prévu pour les métiers en tension
pourquoi c'est si sensible c'est si
sensible parce que déjà d'ores et déjà
les républicains ont dit qu'il ne
voteraient jamais un texte dans lequel
il y aurait cette mesure or e égard à la
situation de majorité relative à
l'Assemblée nationale et bien le
gouvernement ne peut pas se passer des
voies des républicains mais de l'autre
côté celui de la majorité vous avez des
députés qui ne veulent pas d'un texte
qui aurait été fait que pour la droite
et qui au contraire veulent de cette
mesure parce que c'était aussi perçu
comme un signal envoyé en quelque sorte
aux électeurs de centre gauche donc
c'est vrai que Gérald Darmanin est un
peu face à un casse-tête une énigme qui
est difficile à résoudre et son
entourage me disait cet après-midi que
la solution pourrait peut-être être de
réduire le nombre de métiers en tension
concernés justement par ce titre de
séjour même si les consultations ne font
que débuter il a reçu par exemple
aujourd'hui Sacha Oli le président de la
commission des lois à l'Assemblée et
Aurore berger la présidente du groupe
majoritaire à la simple le discours
c'est de dire pour l'instant il est pas
question de supprimer cette position
c'est ça pour l'instant ça traduit quoi
ces tensions ça traduit déjà que Gérald
n'a pas l'intention de laisser tomber ce
texte parce qu'on sait que pour lui
politiquement c'est pas possible que ce
texte ne soit pas voté ce sera un échec
politique et donc que pour cela il est
préféra faire peut-être pas toutes mais
à peu près toutes les concessions
possibles à ses anciens amis droite ça
traduit quand même aussi ensuite des
sinon des dissensions en tout cas des
divergences au sein même du couple
exécutif entre Elisabeth borne
clairement on le sentiment pas que ce
texte sur l'immigration c'est une
priorité c'est pas la vie d'Emmanuel
Macron qui est critiquait depuis
d'ailleurs six ans sur cette question de
l'immigration par la droite et puis ça
traduit aussi une crainte d'une partie
des élus en particulier de renaissance
c'est de revivre avec les républicains
la même chose qu'ils ont vécu finalement
sur leur retraite c'est-à-dire d'avoir
un partenaire qui se fait désirer qui
obtient des concessions et qui au final
n'est pas fiable et finit par se défiler
donc si je vous entends discuter avec
les LR ça ne fait vraiment pas
l'unanimité au sein de la majorité non
par du tout parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
responsables de la majorité aujourd'hui
qui estiment que ça ne sert à rien de
côté négocié avec les républicains sur
ce texte parce qu'ils sont convaincus
qu'au final les républicains ne voteront
pas ce texte c'est quasiment
l'immigration le seul sujet qu'il est
différencie de nous c'est
identitaire pour eux me disait à la
mi-journée une conseillère de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale s'il
vote notre texte il n'existe plus me
disait cette même conseillère de Yelle
Bron Pivet sans les LR quelle solution
Thomas alors s'il en reste une le fameux
49-3 là ce serait extrêmement compliqué
ce serait même une folie il me disait
tout à l'heure une députée mais après ce
qu'on a vu ces dernières semaines tout
est possible est-ce qu'il faut Françoise
Gatel survient là-bas est-ce qu'il faut
vraiment une nouvelle loi immigration
alors qu'il y en a eu je crois plus de
plus de 20 en 30 ans oui je pense si
elles étaient parfaites et
opérationnelles on en reparlera pas moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est un vrai
sujet de préoccupation pour les pour nos
concitoyens et ne pas nommer les choses
et ne pas dire les choses c'est un sujet
et qu'aujourd'hui vous avez aussi des
entreprises qui attendent d'avoir de la
main d'oeuvre étrangère parce qu'on en
trouve pas et que je pense qu'on est
capable d'intégrer dans des conditions
que notre pays doit définir parce que
c'est aussi un projet de société et que
je pense qu'on ne peut pas se contenter
de cette immigration irrégulière qu'on
n'arrive pas à réguler et qu'on n'arrive
pas à reconduire à la frontière et que
les choses ne vont pas cesser parce
qu'on a quand même une appétence on va
dire
considérable de tous ces gens qui sont
dans des pays où ils ne veulent pas
rester pour venir vers nous parce que
c'est comme un adorado mais que il faut
aussi conjuguer une politique d'aide au
développement je pense que c'est
extrêmement important et pouvoir
négocier avec des pays avec lesquels on
peut avoir des accords d'accueil de de
de population des conditions qui soient
acceptables je pense que il faut dire
les choses faites courageux et moi je
pense que parfois la gauche elle se
cache derrière une bien-pensance une
soi-disant
générosité qui en fait conduit au drame
et à de grandes difficultés y compris
pour les gens qui viennent dans notre
pays qui vivent dans des conditions qui
sont d'une indécence folle merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce premier débat bientôt sur public
Sen